jojo wir kochen wird ein tag an nur
treibhaus kitchen gerichte es ist
ähnlich wie auf dem song way back von
gucci mail coaching über sein hobby
michael sack mit michael rieger way back
so dass bei money wollen mir ich bin ein
großes supporter seit tag eins auch
damals als er von allen geherzt wurde
habe ich ihm die stange gehalten aber
zunächst müssen wir den gebührenden
respekt erweisen mal die morgens t shirt
erhältlich auf moneyball punkt at&t
wochen ist das richtige stichwort wir
fangen chicken entworfenes tag an mit
chicken entwickelt das ist
passenderweise die erste folge treffers
kitchen die beim anbau auf dem kanal
online ist und ich habe gestern schon
angefangen das parlament schicken zu
marilyn also schicken stripes wie sie
selbst hat in seinem video hühnerbrust
genutzt ich habe das schon fertige karte
gekauft auf jeden fall genauso wie er
vorbereitet und jetzt über nacht merial
hängen lassen und kurz bevor das video
richtig losgeht ich möchte einmal kurz
bedanken dafür wie es in letzter zeit
auf einem kanal ab geht alles kommt
super war ich an und liebe hat mich auf
die idee gebracht hat beim letzten mal
gesagt von euch haben 76 prozent main
kanal nicht abonniert mein persönliches
ziel für dieses jahr ist es eine million
autos zu erreichen ich kann sehen wie
viele einzelne zuschauer ich im monat
habe das sind ungefähr 800.000 das heißt
es ist eigentlich so einfach von den 66
prozent die immer meine videos schauen
müssen nur ein paar abonnieren im
viertel oder so und ich hatte meine
million aber ich weiß das ist nicht
realistisch ist nichtsdestotrotz zahlt
ihr gerne meinen videos schaut überlegt
euch der noch wenig vielleicht auch ein
kanal abonnieren wollt ich würde mich
damit sehr unterstützen
wir legen jetzt los mit mir in worms so
eine kleine anekdote woher ich schicken
models kenne das ok tue ich wirklich aus
der ersten kleinen sketchen epic wurde
aber zum ersten mal probiert habe ich
kein wolf bis 2018
da war ich bei einem
event von tiefer und dort habe ich
geantwortet probiert wir waren im green
room da waren auch wird ja die unter
anderem ein paar erfolgreiche infekte
und dann war kam zu einer so richtig
korrekter typ kamen so rein hat sich
hingesetzt mit seinen homies und meinte
so blieb stehen jetzt was zu essen
ich mag alles gut wir hatten da auch
essen man sehr wenig dann kam so dass
gästen so richtig große platten so mit
alufolie da drauf waren schicken entwurf
ist und ich habe das so gesehen und ich
kannte das ja vermeiden wird so schmeckt
das wirklich hab so ein bisschen mit dem
typen geredet dann machst du da
probieren das problem hat gab es die
gäste nicht als übels gefeiert und das
krasse ich wusste dass gar nicht gemeint
ist seit die aus deutschland oder also
es war logischerweise englisch manchmal
seid ihr auch deutschland nicht so josef
also ja ich wollte schon die ganze zeit
mal hin dass minister austauschen und
dann zeigst du merkst du mich rum wenn
ich in deutschland wird immer gerne
kannte ihn nicht
folge mir so leid ich sehe so youtube
mit schuster erfolgreicher nfl spieler
und er war so projekt haben wir das
alles gezeigt deshalb ist es auf jeden
fall ein besonderes gericht für mich
also das kicken sie als marilyn
wir fangen erst mal an mit dem teig mit
dem rock natürlich haben sich meine
freude und familie nicht lumpen lassen
und als sie gehört haben also zwischen
einem ort machen an besagtem auch drauf
deshalb habe ich sehr große passion
gemacht man die benutzer selbst ist ein
video von amazon pancakes als ich damals
in
amerika habe ich mir natürlich auch von
normalisierung geholt aber ich habe
dummerweise den leipzig geholt
dementsprechend wird gefällt wir haben
100 gramm butter schmelzen wert sogar
auf jetzt schön von zusammen ehe
wirklich leute ich glaube das ist der
koch tag auf den ich mich am meisten
freue
auch wenn ich über die feiertage an
meinem gut immerhin gangster bauch
gearbeitet habe dementsprechend jetzt
eigentlich ein bisschen slow keeper mit
ungesundem essen aber das ist die
perfekte ausrede 500 gramm mehl so dran
benötigen je 100 gramm zucker an zwei
pakete backpulver mehr weißes pulver in
eine kleine prise salz und ein paket man
edel zugang soll die trockenen zutaten
verrühren jetzt wann dann werden wir zu
dem ganzen einen liter buttermilch polar
aber nicht anders als in dem rap game
und dann noch vier große eier da das
ganze vermengen werd ich muss ganz kurz
sagen wirklich money boy bei einem eine
große inspiration mit dem kochen
anzufangen
money boy auch der erste dessen kopf wie
das nicht geschaut habe triphaus kitchen
ist meiner meinung nach wirklich das
beste koch format auf youtube das ist
meine hommage jetzt auf jeden fall an
bisi und dann sein format hinterlässt
ein bisschen stehen damit das backpulver
und das mehl activated werden
ich war schon mal eine fritteuse und
meine waffe erhalten auch zunächst
brauchen wir ein ghetto gefrierbeutel
dann auch schauen dass ganze treppchen
hinein gehen wir
in dem weißen pulver eine gute menge
dann werden wir dabei noch ein bisschen
maisstärke und da kommen wir unsere
spies rhein ein bisschen salz nicht zu
viel haben benötigen etwas chili powder
vor ort werden wir brauchen ein bisschen
kritisch zu lang
nur noch kathrin peter jenische kräuter
ich hatte ganz vergessen die butter zu
üben zudem teilt aber marta warten
so werden jetzt hier unsere
gewürzmischung und die müssen wir jetzt
ein bisschen vom mischen ja doch mal mit
den händen rein und hier ein turnier
schicken strips die wir vorbereitet
haben sind sehr sehr nah ist auf jeden
fall schließen wir denn jetzt war das
ist wirklich trepte das chicken ist so
sagt ich natürlich eine situation mit
der sich manni vorläufig häufiger
konfrontiert sieht als ich mit dem
weißen pulver zu wirken aber ich schlage
mich auch ganz gut war okay ein rack
schicken stripes parallelwelten das
waffeleisen ein bisschen wichtig ist
dass das belgische waffen sind wie sie
als 1 was man drehen kann um 180 grad
das natürlich noch nicht aber ich habe
dieses hier
das hätten wir auf jeden fall dann
können wir auch schon her gehen so ein
schönes group von unserem teich hinein
geben muss man immer aufpassen dass man
nicht zu viel redet es muss aber
trotzdem sehr schön ausgefüllt sein
ähnlich wie das könnte schon zu viel
sein
sie baten den ersten backvorgang ab da
gehen ja auch schon rüber nummer eins
zwei drei
und jetzt tauchten wir das ganze ab
disco braun ist
[Musik]
so leute ja jetzt gesehen türkin morgens
auf dem start schicken models auf dem
place ich mache jetzt den test test wir
haben noch mehr geschockt darüber
gemacht hier ein stiller anschnitt von
unseren drei schicken und so ein tenders
bisschen hoffe dass so eine serie
geschmackskombinationen das täglich
immer zurück zu dem moment mit youtube
in l e für mich das nichts neues schon
öfters mal was nach gemacht habe von
moneyball aber die gerichte tier machte
durch alle sagen aber mit umso mehr
freut mich aufs mittagessen wir sehen
uns bleibt so leute kommen wir auch zu
mittag essen heute mittag gibt es ein
mcjob in mcdonough in den 90er jahren in
chicago zu ihren von michael jordan ich
habe deshalb auch hier die passenden
schuhe an
wir brauchen nur eine handvoll zutaten
wir haben hier ein sesame burger bahn
will für meine bürger immer gerne prior
schwanz aber das ist quasi dem
originalrezept nachempfunden dann
brauchen wir gurken waren diverse geräte
benutzt ich habe solche körper dafür
schneidet ja was uns in kleine scheiben
wir benötigen sind smoke bacon drei
strategies bisschen zwiebel die wir
würfeln
also hier ein paar schöne zwiebeln wenn
ich noch ein bisschen mehr für den
background von lektoren interessiert
dann checkt auf jeden fall die körper
sketchen folge ab hier auf jeden fall
mal alles vorschreiben scheller und habe
mir meinen rindfleisch martin bauer hat
ist von seinem mietpark bekommt frisch
geräusch mit einem höheren fettanteil
das macht das ganze noch mal ein
bisschen geiler
ich habe jetzt kurzfristig nur dass hier
bekommen davon 400
aktien haben wenn ihr fragt warum 113
gramm das ist ein kollaps also ein
viertel 5 und das ist ein bisschen zu
viel und das ist ein portabler der baar
kreis und voller power das ist eine
typische bürger größe in amerika weit
über 130 gramm genommen ich werde ihm
gleichtun
113,0 ebenfalls leider keine burger fest
wird sie das erst mal ein bisschen habe
ich jetzt mal so leichtfertig schon raus
ist ein corder bounty und dann treffe
ich das klar ja ich denke wenn man halt
noch ein bisschen nachhilfe sind wir auf
einem guten weg fast umgekehrt von der
größe ist band dass wir auch dazu geben
und dann könnt ihr auch schon sogar zum
grillen und den rechen fertig machen so
wir packen erst mal in deggendorf sowie
thorsten die nur von einer seite an das
hat man den ball genau so gemacht
in den becken fed sich jetzt die bremse
und hier drüben liegt das party auf wir
hätten den kies
[Musik]
da kann es auch schon losgehen mit dem
exempel sohn wir belegen den burger
upside down fangen an mit coversongs
dann kommt unser bacon ist nicht ultra
crosby ich habe da eine aufregung als
manipuliert hat glaube das ist eine der
neiße variation der geruch und unsere
ornithologen dann unsere bürger partie
ich habe den fehler aber ich wollte
eigentlich ab seiten bauen papst
persönlich richtig gemacht
[Musik]
der ärger so gut ich habe ganz vergessen
die kamera an zu machen
ich habe eine cola mit eis der bürger
also was soll ich sagen
nicht umsonst gibt moneyball den bürgern
in 12 von 10 für mich sagt auch so zu
fastfood so authentisch dass ich noch
gar nicht kenne weil das hat 1991 er ist
dieses rezept besten schmeckte
mietkosten nach mekka weist
wir sehen uns zum abendessen es gibt mit
bus mit marinade source und kurz bevor
ich loslege mit dem abendessen an dieser
stelle eine öffentliche einladung an
money boy ich hab mich ein tag für
verschiedene gäste kochen bis herzlich
eingeladen der gast zu sein
wir fahren auf jeden fall mit unsere
marina resort sun dazu ich mache mir
jetzt einen pop den er gern wenig
olivenöl dass der boden gecovert ist
hinstellen jetzt auf dem herd und lassen
die langsam heiß werden
der zwischenzeit wirklich hier eine
zwiebel für die zwiebel geben wir jetzt
in unseren top 4 1
schwitzen sie dort an bis sie glasig ist
so ein bisschen vor 13 sollten gut sein
sehr gut frisch gepresster knoblauch
zwiebeln sind sehr schön basiert dann
geben wir es auch um die hälfte von dem
noch hinzu und einheit 10 decke droht
es ist an farbe zu bekommen nehmen wir
geschälte tomaten dazu dass sie sind
jetzt aus parma noch besser sagen wir
dazu waren um ihr seht leute das können
wir jetzt ebenfalls passierte tomaten
hinzu dann fügen wir dem ganzen salz hin
zu frisch geriebenen pfeffer chili
flocken oder das ganze köchelt jetzt für
40 minuten kurz vor schluss kommen auch
frischer basilikum dazu machen wir
weiter mit dem mietwagen eine blaue
schüssel war wird es drei verschiedene
sorten hab ich bin mal wieder nur einem
winter unterwegs
das gebe ich hier hinein das habe ich
hier hinein gegeben
hinzu kommt ein wenig salz pfeffer 1 1
haben wir kriegen wir einen tender
gröbchen und semmelbrösel gleich aber
erst mal schneiden die das hamburger
berühmten streifen sehr gut davon leben
wir es schriftlich ein bisschen was dazu
halt mich erst mit dem rest zurück weil
ich habe wenig wind dann kommt selber
brüssel hinzu
nach gefühl ist hier die mengenangabe
reihen wieder auffrischen parmigiano so
davon gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen rein
wenn ich geglaubt dass es genug ist gibt
es noch ein bisschen hinzu dann
benötigen wir ebenfalls frischem
basilikum weil wir ein bisschen zusammen
in einem boot da wird dann zeigen wir
unseren basilikum hinzu und ein wenig
unsere frischen knoblauch jedenfalls
knoblauch und zwiebel pulver noch und
jetzt könnten wir das ganze durch
um eine halte ich die frisch gehackte
petersilie vergessen hätte unschöne
folgen haben können deshalb sehr gut das
ist jetzt noch rein enden kann
die frischen aroma und die gehen wir
dann auch noch dazu arbeiten wir auch
noch ein so dass das unser riesen meat
boy stehen wir weitere kleine mit boards
von werden bin sehr gespannt also hat so
nice geschmeckt als bisher dass ich
jetzt auch diese passt da nicht freuen
man muss auch sagen im vergleich zu den
anderen beiden sachen wie heute hatte
ich das sogar relativ herti ich muss mir
ganz selbstkritisch zu bestehen dass ich
ein bisschen gelegt habe was die exotik
stoners angeht ich bin auch ein sehr
großer fan von ex alex oder von grapes
oder pineapple alles mögliche fahrer
habe ich heute nicht besorgt genutzt
hier genau wie money boy de cecco
spaghetti und die fahren jetzt jetzt
langsam heiß das heißt wir geben die mit
boris rhein
[Musik]
ich kann es nicht erwarten hier
reinzulegen leute wirklich so
die soße decke hoch wirklich dimitros
den schönen frauen von allen seiten
professionisten mit ball perfekt durch
sich sehr gut mir noch einen tipp von
der marina crazy knusprig außen geraten
innen drin weiß oft die marinade hatten
leichte schärfe unfassbar fruchtig die
soße man merkt dass der ganze tomaten
und sind und vor allen dingen sind die
mieter sehr schlammig war was soll ich
sagen ich hatte schon eine vorahnung
dass dieses video gut wird das ist
lecker wird aber dass sie so lecker wird
hätte ich nicht gedacht haben das gerne
leicht aber es euch gefallen hat alle
treffer zwischen videos zu verlegen wir
sehen uns berichten die dir wieder
sonntags nur ca